i can bring you in warm
okay
bring it in both how about a nice
baby bear right in the middle
oh this is so great
already he's like all right you know
what
i'm done screwing around
i like how he's not
oh he had to drag it like it's heavy
yeah
i love the combat here this is sick oh
he burned himself
he's not worthy you should have known
mando
what if he just made him like a really
cool sword
oh it looks like champagne
helmet for him yeah that'd be great just
made him a bug spawning chain it looks
like him it looks like how did she tie
it so perfectly looks like his ears
it's got to be the same one for before
right
yeah yeah something wrong
there's only like three x-wing pilots in
this entire universe
it's like getting pulled over by the
same cop twice
that one's new though that's um that's
the guy who did the luke skywalker
stand-in from mandalorian
okay yeah that's him your engine model
doesn't match your powers that's so cool
that they got him to do a cameo here
him yeah yeah but but it's still you you
still have to stand in for sebastian's
dance face that we're going to put him
still yeah we're also mapping his face
there'll never be a uh
a holy practical luke skywalker never
welcome back to new rock stars the book
of boba fett episode 5 the return of the
mandalorian asks boba who and just
delivered more mandalorian payoff that
fans have been craving but you know we
didn't think that we would see until
another mandalorian season
is this the book of boba fett or did
jocasta new put the cover jacket on a
book about the dark saber what is that
also what's the deal with the book uh
component of this we haven't seen any
books on this show i understand it's a
it's a bible chapter idea but just show
us a book at some point please
give us a couple books give us a novella
please well this is wikileaks new rock
stars mandalorian after a book of boba
fett after show and it's our weekly
reaction to the latest in star wars i'm
eric boss my easter egg breakdown for
this episode is going to come out
tomorrow but right now i'm here with
tommy bechtold whoa lee what an episode
oh my goodness that was that made me
feel like a kid again that was a
very star wars-y
uh
revelations around every corner episode
it was amazing yeah uh star wars is back
in the stars now folks we're off world
we're we're in amazing production design
it's like the budget for this episode
compared to like i feel like the first
four episodes had like a qu each a
quarter of the budget of this episode it
was insane yeah like there was a bit of
a whiplash that i felt but like a good
kind of whiplash i'm not complaining
tommy and i were talking about how the
uh clone wars would do this a lot that
you'd be watching just four episodes of
one arc and then suddenly
maul and his brother in towson would be
there doing some creepy witchcraft and
you're just like is this the same show
yes it's all the same show because the
star wars universe is filled with
different characters and actually kind
of love this idea that any one of these
shows could just jump over to another
character from one of the other shows
it's kind of exciting that way i don't
care what the show's called just give me
star wars every week and they wasted no
time they were like all right we uh we
teased mando in the last episode and he
is yeah this show is now the mandalorian
season three
so we're not gonna hold back yes no half
measures right i'm i am fully stoked
after this episode now uh i am still in
a different studio set up for everyone
watching i just moved into a new
apartment into a new city actually um so
i haven't yet got my camera set up so if
i'm often looking below your eye line it
doesn't mean i love you any less it
means i love you more and i want to just
make sure i get what i get my notes
right okay so let's uh remind ourselves
what happened in this amazing episode
episode five shifted from the sans of
tatooine and uh all those repeat
flashback does to just some good raw
mando action and this time butchering
the butchers what a fascinating setting
to open in a butcher shop they showed us
with mando the
aggression people were hoping to get
from boba fett like that was like the
brutality that i think people were
hoping to have uh
like you know the bounty hunter that is
ruthless and instead we've got kind of
gotten this benevolent like i will rule
with bureaucracy and peace boba fett and
we got mando is just wilding out with
the darkness and one of the great ways
that they've always choreographed uh
denjarin on this series is the fact that
he's still a bit sloppy you know he he
hasn't mastered the darksaber he's
dragging it around he cuts himself with
it i think that's one of the best things
about his character is he's he's a
badass he's a warrior he can take out
like a room full of people but he's
going to walk away limping you know like
he's going to hurt himself uh so i i i
you can still make someone fierce and
ferocious
as long as you give them scars as a
result of those fights so yeah this
fight ends when mando uses the dark
saber to collect this bounty on this
platoonian kabab
slicing him in half ruining that butcher
apron for anyone else who want to use it
you know there's some butchers in the
back are like hey yeah new york public
credit's great i don't know when the new
republic is going to be toppled but i'd
love to have a better apron i guess i
can't now thanks
stranger um but yeah i just love this
idea that he scalds his own leg and you
know it's just that classic thing as
cool of a weapon as you get you'll burn
your leg off and that is exactly what
happened you're burning your leg off kid
so mando returns this bounty just the
dripping head to one of the coolest
settings i think we've ever seen in star
wars it's this massive ribbon city that
orbits a star got an incomplete end so
that the sun's shadow causes a shift
from day to night but it seems to happen
real fast kind of like a pokemon yellow
or is it gold and silver when it started
to shift day and night just kind of
suddenly or no it would match your own
time this is way faster you just have
like you're gonna be chasing the night
as you run across this awesome 3d scape
i thought it was so cool i love this
idea um but as cool as that setting is
you know the survivor mandalorians have
to find the grimiest darkest place in
order to hide from the rest of the
sadness the substrata most wide open
into the like dark vacuums of space just
exposed at all times because yeah the
armor is gonna say you cannot expose
yourself in cities there's going to be
nukes that hit you t2 style battle
droids who will mow you down and then
we'll weep a thousand tears for you
this is the way to stay in the dark i'm
not complaining this area looks cool too
this kind of halo setting of a giant
space drop beneath your feet
no complaints um so we find out that
what's left of the mandalorians is
really just the armorer and paz visla
john favreau himself playing the uh the
heir of house of isla i think we can
assume yeah yes
i would say so after this episode
definitely yeah um so the armorer really
just dumps all the burning questions we
had about mandalorian history again we
have to remind you in a show called the
book of boba fett but i love this
because we learn we get some
confirmations about the history of the
dark saber we have some fun reaction
shots of pas visa it was just like right
in the middle of them as the
sword is between them like can i just
grab this because it's mine our family
name's on the
hill um we get this history of what
happened in the great purge the night of
a thousand tears how the death watch was
on the moon of concordia uh the moon
named concordia not the moon of kind
whatever um and allow them to survive
those imperial bombers and then this
total terminator 2 judgement day
yes k2so clones just for the super
battle droids yeah i mean
it was it was nasty and i loved it and i
think my favorite thing about this is
that the armorer might be an unreliable
narrator because she's totally
uh this cult figure right uh she has her
version of these events that uh just
preserve the way of life for her
mandalorian survivors but that doesn't
mean that she's telling the 100 percent
truth there may have been other
circumstances there may have been other
mandalorian survivors we know that's the
case because of bo katan is still
running around out there with costco
reeves so it's not like just because
they had their own weird way of life on
the moon is the only reason they
survived and it's not just because of
some weird curse of this dark saber
being handed down to her as a gift as
opposed to her winning it by the creed
that caused this but i just love that
like it casts her whole story with a bit
of like religious superstition and i
there is a truth to it of course because
i i think obviously swords being won via
combat is
is there's value to that it's how you
gain the respect to the next generation
that you truly earned this position uh
but the fact that somehow it led to the
these thai bombers wiping out the city
surface yeah but i just love that that
we're meant to cast it in a little doubt
yeah and it was it was a very extreme
kind of doomsday
telling of what happened to everyone and
also kind of an indictment of boca ten
we got that fi like we finally
understand in this saga and in the show
like what she did
to end up where she is like what
happened her failed kind of
attempt to unite mandalore right and i
think again another question answered
from the mandalorian season two where
she had that look of the dark saber
needing to be won by combat and where i
wanted well you didn't who did you fight
to receive it this episode answered that
as well um now den ends up surrendering
his best scar spear because they believe
that all best guards should be uh forged
into armor defensive things as opposed
to weaponry which another great little
detail that i liked so they decided to
reforge it i was wondering are we gonna
get a little grogu helmet um i think
this chain mail whatever this is is uh
is a wonderful choice now the armorer
spars with denjarin but amanda struggles
with the dark sabers increasing weight
which lends some credulity to the
mysticism of this sword you know darks
all lightsabers are supposed to be
you know a bit more lightweight than
your average sword but this kind of
brings it back to what george lucas
originally conceived for these swords
there's supposed to be slow battles
there's supposed to be some weight to
the hilts uh and now we finally get to
see that which is just it was really fun
um to see it weighing more and more on
him as he was further and further
proving himself unworthy of it and this
leads to pacifism just being like yeah
this this guy can't handle it so he i'm
taking this back this is off uh
i love that they were like well this the
only way to do this fight fair is if we
both get rid of our chat right yeah uh
so mando ends up winning but he reveals
he hit one point in the past he cannot
tell a lie he took off his helmet
and these two immediately say well it
doesn't matter if you're the best hope
for survival for us [ __ ] off you're out
get out
yeah we hate you you're dead to us
i mean they're serious like
they they're superstition it's oh
they're walking around with their
helmets off and that's why it got bombed
i'm telling you well i feel like she she
the armorer knew that he had done that
and that's why she asked that felt like
she was probably hoping that um paz
fizzler would just win but since he
didn't she was like all right i'll play
my trump card which is i know you took
your helmet off
yeah um
so mando then flies commercial to
tatooine he has to check in all of his
weapons really i was wondering is
something gonna happen to his dark saber
is someone gonna steal it or sabotage it
really it just seemed like a gag to just
show all the insane amounts of weapons
he has to unload and constantly has it
was the like
it was like the cowboy thing of like
turn in all your guns and then like you
turn in four and then they're like the
rest of them and you pull like two more
out of your socks like
he had so he had so many weapons um well
after having a cute moment with a
rhodian kid on the flight he gets to
tatooine reunites with pelemoto
uh and hopes to get a new razor crest
but instead she is building for him an
n1 starfighter last seen defending naboo
and phantom menace
and they acquire more spare parts from
jobless we learned that peliboto used to
date a jawa
amy sateris just pulling out the great
improv lines here
sure oh my god it was hilarious this
episode she said that jaws are this
particular jaw was very furry a lot of
issues what was that java's issue i
have to wonder that was that was insane
because yeah like you said that had to
have been improvised and they were like
leave it in yeah it's definitely
this character is crazy enough that that
that could have happened
i just want like a flashback to with amy
sedaris on a date with this awful day
with this job where he's just talking to
him
oh my god
and the jaw was just like taking
everything off the table and putting it
in like the trade he steals all the
sugar packets you never know if you can
just do one of those swaps
swap your way up to a telescope with one
of those
exactly but uh i love how the other jawa
later asks her out she's still just you
know
she's doing her own thing she's just
focusing on her now she's been robbed
the wrong way and she's yeah she's going
somewhere the jawas are all about amy
sedaris they're like she has her own
shop
she's hilarious she's funny she's a
charmer she's a keeper someone's got to
get like there's some jawa parents who's
like
well then the next brother has to go hit
on this mechanic because she's a catch
go get her brian out loud she's a small
business owner also she's got this new
droid that we didn't see before a bd
droid yes was it bd1 from jedi fallen
order friend to calcastus no it looks
like bd5 was this one but it's i love
that they brought in this droid class i
don't think we've ever seen it live
actually it'd be great to see calcus
jump into one of these shows see where
this kid ended up i had like flashbacks
to playing fall in order and not knowing
what to do and then asking bd1 and bd1
not really helping me and then me asking
again hoping bd1 would say something
different and it's still not healthy
and then me just rage going to youtube
and being like how do you get out of
this planet
and then you see like a video with me
and you're like no no that's not helping
no not that guy
i know him from work
that's my piece of friend from work
well mando takes this uh this in one
starfighter on a test drive through
beggars canyon this is amazing uh again
this episode proves you can actually
leave a planet's atmosphere on star wars
and as mando uh floats around in space
he goes past a commercial line and runs
into a couple x-wing pilots of course
paul and hung lee returns as captain
carson teva from the mandalorian even
recognized his voice but he's now joined
by lieutenant reed who's played by max
lloyd jones who was the stand-in actor
for luke skywalker's cameo and the
mandalorian last season so the episode
ends with fenix shan recruiting mando as
muscle top boba fett but mando offers to
do it for free but first wants to
reconnect with grogu
but the real question is does grogu want
to connect with him
how has that child changed
why does he want to reconnect and will
it be as smooth and there might be a dog
shadow behind me right now and that's
because darla had some questions about
grogu
darla's also like i want to reconnect
oh i always want to reconnect with that
sweetie i'm mean
well before we get into this our merch
partners at epic hero shop have a new
shirt for their latest obsession series
inspired by the book of boba fett
they're limited edition so grab one
before they are gone and when you buy a
latest obsession shirt you'll get the
added option to write in a custom shout
out that will appear along the bottom of
this book of boba fett after shows
one of the shout outs was from matthew
this week he said if you need permission
to kill a hut is leia constantly being
hunted by the family or forgiven a great
question from earlier episodes matthew
yeah i want we're still waiting to find
out who you need permission from to kill
a hut who grants that permission is it
just uh three fifths of the other huts
who have to have like a 60
majority in order to make that decision
i think
i think that party barge was such a
debacle they're just like sweep it under
the rug let's just not mention it like
we'll just pretend it didn't happen yeah
i think so uh carol says what's up eric
and tommy do you think there's a chance
that if boba gets din mayfeld comes too
um yeah i'm ready to like if we could
just have some of these episodes just be
mandalorian episodes yeah get bill burr
back in here why not let's just have a
half a season of mandalorian
yeah just toss the final two episodes
are just going to be mayfield walking
around scrapyards screaming at people
and they're going to be great what's
going on
uh and then brandon says i want to see
boba slam dunk at syracuse orange game
over boheim
okay yeah bayheim this is the syracuse
reference thank you for correcting me
new york the carrier dome buddy beyheim
jimmy behind okay jim behind the coach
thought julie behind the wife the whole
family boba just dunking on all of them
with his jet pack a 60 year old man
dunking on an 80 year old man and while
his two 20-year-old kids and his
50-year-old wife look on that's what i
think
what brandon i'd love to see i would too
i now now that i had this visual in my
head i have to see this in my background
check all of our merch out at
nurakstarsmerch.com
so tommy what is our first question
coming out of this episode well eric let
me ask you what the fact will happen
when din jaren tries to reunite with
grogu what did he actually forge for
yeah for now all we really saw clearly
was that adorable bundle uh a nice like
perfect little knot that just looks like
the grow goose
what an incredible like
you know the armorer
is like the expert rapper she's like no
i will just wrap all the gifts because i
will make the gift look like the person
you're giving it i'll make them crisp i
will use just the right amount i'll use
one piece of tape one piece of tape is
all that is necessary
to seal the whole seal the whole thing
and when you cut the ribbon the whole
thing will nicely unfold and then
butterflies will fly out
but uh before that it looked we had a
brief shot of like chain mail pieces of
chains falling down so it looks like
they're going to make some kind of chain
mail armor for grogu knee thrill
style armor for the child which i think
is great because we don't know how that
kid's gonna grow you want some chain
mail that can be you know adjusted you
don't want one thing where they gotta
like hammer it hammer it out as the kid
gets fatter you need something that can
be malleable adjustable you know can
protect them everyone knows
when it comes to kids you buy two sizes
up so they can grow but i think
yeah exactly he'll grow into it and but
i think that is exactly uh an
interesting clue for
what denjarin is expecting running into
the child right now because he doesn't
know how this child has changed yes it
only seems to be like what a couple of
weeks in the present timeline of the
book above it after the ending of the
mandalorian season two but he doesn't
know this kid's biology he doesn't know
what jedi training will do to it or
where this kid's future is if he's going
to want to stay with dinger and come
back to him or go off on his own but he
wants this kid to always be protected no
matter how he changes over the course of
his life so um
i was just kind of curious what
triggered dinjaran's sudden desire to
check in on grogu uh like
does he just miss him it's only been a
couple of weeks i understand missing
this kid but you have to trust him to go
off to college and make his own choices
but i'm wondering if there could be
some kind of new distrust like some kind
of uh empty nester syndrome where he has
some doubts about the cult that he just
handed this kid off to um
and i think it's all coming from the
dark saber uh there's this interesting
line with armor says in order to master
the ways of the force
jedi must forgo all attachment and
amanda responds well that is the
opposite of our creed loyalty and
solidarity are the way now this is
essentially the armorer repeating
something that ahsoka tano warned mando
about back in uh
chapter 14 or whatever that episode was
season two episode five
on kaladan um that is uh i think a
suspicion that mando's always had about
the jedi and really it was the fact that
luke skywalker saved them on that ship
at the end of last season that he's kind
of like well
i think this guy can trust i think this
guy let's give him a chance but now
after carrying this dark saber hurting
himself with it seeing it feels like too
powerful of a weapon i think
he's kind of had he has that natural
instinct that if you think about it
mandalorians have always hated jedi or
distrusted them because historically
they've been at war with them for like
decades for generations yeah they don't
trust these freaking wizards even though
uh taravisla was both a mandalorian a
jedi he was the you know the exception
to the rule most of the time
mandalorians do not like jedi and don't
trust them and i think that uh instinct
is kicking in and he's worried what this
education will do to grogu and maybe he
should be worried uh i think the
implication is that we should be worried
about grogu right now um
right and i liked how the armorer
lectured us about the way the dark saber
really is a weapon that cuts both ways
forged by tar visla ancestor deposviesla
founder of the house visa
both a mandalorian and a jedi but the
armorer claims it carries a curse
that since bokutan was gifted this saber
that she did not win it by creed through
combat uh the armorer believes that is
why the planet of mandalore was bombed
in that night of a thousand tears the
great purge now we don't know if that is
exactly the causal reason to a kitty
bomb it sounds like superstition yeah
connecting two things that may be
correlated seems like uh
escape
for what could have been a larger
bureaucratic uh disagreement that
resulted in violence like
when that saber was handed to bogatan in
rebels there was like a
cry out in the force and then mob gideon
was like a thousand voices
[Music]
there's an imbalance that must be fixed
but i love that that's what mom does
that's what she believes and i think
it's so great to be presented this uh
this superstition as truth
and that's what star wars i believe is
all about like we were
educated in the ways of the jedi code
but really it is a superstition it's
religious fanaticism according to han
solo and we're seeing another side to
that now that i think is just so pure
and so interesting and i would love to
see if when we eventually get to
mandalore if the truth that was
presented to us may not be totally true
that sure the the planet surface was
bombed but there could be of course some
other reason why that happened
um and there
at the end of the day even though it is
religious fanaticism there is some truth
to it because bogotan did seem to
grimace when uh denjarin offered her the
saber at the end of last season like she
seemed to at least know that according
to the surviving mandalorians out there
she doesn't want to risk it she she's
now asking
she can't go that way again she can't
she can't just get it again yeah it
can't just be gifted to her again she's
got to win it she's got to prove them
well i guess in this case proving them
wrong would be just to take it and show
that it wasn't connected but i think she
has now made this her truth that she
understands that she's brought in yeah
she's gonna win them over she has to
show okay well this time i'm gonna win
it back and right that wrong but this
blade does have real mystic qualities to
it it does weigh heavily on someone who
it seems like may not be totally worthy
of wielding it yet that hasn't properly
earned it maybe by defeating uh
like if you think about it mando really
defeated a usurper of this blade who is
not a mandalorian and didn't even swear
by any kind of mandalorian way of life
but
uh everyone else has to kind of win it
from a mandalorian
and eventually that blade kind of puts a
curse on you to where it's gonna be hard
to wield it
um and that's a real thing that we saw a
real physical effect that we saw yeah he
cuts himself right right um so i think
after he cut himself tommy uh that is
when mando might have started to view
this as a burden and a curse uh that his
lifelong jedi superstition has started
to kick in and i think he now feels like
it might have been a mistake to entrust
his best buddy to the freaky sorcerers
who use these kind of weapons
yeah and i think you know
when you
you establish the bond that grogu and
and mando had it's uh
this is the way to explain why he would
go back for him right like otherwise it
didn't make any sense only if mando had
second thoughts about it like that's
this is the logical way to get them back
in the same scene together so i i
thought it was well and i also think
it's it makes us wonder should we be
worried for grogu's well-being because
we should also remember that this era of
luke skywalker despite being a badass
jedi warrior he's really at the height
of his pride he's now at the stages in
his career where he's obsessing over the
jedi code he's uh traveling all over the
galaxy trying to assemble the ancient
jedi texts he's trying to rebuild the
jedi order page turners they are not
trying to rebuild a jedi order with his
nephew he has not yet been burned by his
arrogance and come out to his more
grounded understanding of the force
that's going to be decades from now so i
think we have to ask ourselves in the
short time that grogu has been with luke
skywalker how has luke changed grogu
like
will groku have suddenly aged rapidly
could he be talking now is he gonna have
some crazy scary force abilities where
he just force chokes everything is that
gonna be a behavior that luke might have
encouraged because we saw luke use it on
one of those droids when he rescued them
and is it really gonna have to be mando
having to rescue grogu from the darker
path of the jedi ways and instead forge
a new mandalorian clan starting with the
two of them
is that the answer that awaits him in
these living waters beneath the mines of
mandalore what do you think tommy ah you
know i
i'm really interested it seems to me as
if what is being set up now is that
maybe grogu's destiny is not to become a
jedi but just a force
wielding being you know what i mean and
like you said member of maybe a new
mandalorian clan but maybe like the
whole focus and obsession with getting
him to a jedi is now
seemingly the wrong path
with grogus kind of like impulsive
violent
instincts as a as a young child
maybe it's safer for him to just kind of
have these force abilities but not fully
focus them on the jedi path which could
you know lead to a sith path or lead to
a darker path either way so i kind of
think that
what we're learning here is that grogu
is not meant to be a jedi
i think that's kind of the message of
this and
mando has come to that conclusion or is
coming to that conclusion and he's going
to try and take him yeah
i think i think really the implication
that we knew from the end of last season
is if luke was more successful of a
mentor and a teacher to grogu wouldn't
groggu still be at his side at the time
of the jedi temple when everything bad
happened with ben solo like
we worried that did kylo ren kill grogu
is that some i don't think that would be
possible and
you know at his lowest power groga would
at least be a ta who could have kicked
kylo ren's ass um so i think the
implication is that grogu might have
been luke skywalker's first failure as a
teacher you know and then luke just kind
of tried again with his nephew and it
was even worse when it happened with his
nephew so i but the only way that that
failure could not have fully taught luke
skywalker well enough to abandon the
ways of the jedi code would be if he
didn't get enough time if he felt like
if i were only given more time to train
this student and forge a relationship
yeah it was less of a failure and more
of a right and i think mando senses this
i think he sees a kind of evil in this
dark saber a curse that it does not
serve the mandalorian way and i but also
he has found that like
his his mandalorian cult isn't really a
true home for him anymore so i'm hoping
that he can really forge the true way
between the mandalorian and the jedi
ways that kind of takes the best of both
worlds in uh and forges an alliance
that's based on true companionship but
not one that like forces you to hide
your face and have no empathy for anyone
else
yeah yeah you know maybe once in a while
get a little sun on there um so i'm
dying to know what these uh living
waters will be if we will see them this
season i don't know how much time there
is if but it's i yeah uh i imagined like
the weird age of ultron uh waters that
that thor goes to yeah yeah yes yes i
totally think i i think that's a
mandalorian season three
plot point i think that was setting that
up of like
those waters are inaccessible now so
they're you know mando loves a good
quest loves a good task i want to talk
more about those living waters in a
second but first uh thanks to magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode we all
love delicious sweet treats but if you
are trying to eat clean and mean like
boba of tatooine magic spoon can help
magic spin cereal has zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly gluten-free grain free soy free
and low carb grab yourself a variety
pack of four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and peanut butter and then try
mixing flavors chocolate peanut butter
are so good together frosted and fruity
go really great together so go to
magicspoon.comwookieleaks to grab a
variety pack and try it today and be
sure to use our promo code of wikileaks
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
wikileaks and use the code wookie leaks
to save five dollars off and again we
thank magic spoon for sponsoring this
episode we also want to thank manscape
for sponsoring this episode black
cursanting can really pull off that
shaggy look but lots of us don't want to
join the 4 million men worldwide who
trust manscape to keep their downstairs
looking trim with our exclusive offer go
to manscape.com and use the code wookie
for 20 off and free shipping you don't
want to be like daddy gemstone in a
recent episode of the righteous
gemstones i watched that i'm like you
know what he could have used manscaped
that would have helped him out that
would have avoided it that was my
thought i said the manscape lawnmower
that would have saved saved so much
trouble well this year we all want you
to take your package to the next level
with their performance package 4.0 and
brand new ultra premium body wash the
performance package 4.0 has the
signature lawnmower 4.0 with advanced
skin safe technology to reduce cuts and
nicks and the new product that needs no
introduction the ultra premium body wash
from manscaped it's cologne infused with
aloe vera and sea salt to keep your skin
feeling nice clean and moisturized
whether your resolution is to work out
more or travel to new places be sure to
travel to manscape.com for our exclusive
offer get 20 off and free shipping with
the code wookie at manscape.com that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use the code wookie
it's new year no pubes in 2022 with
manscaped
yes i wanted to ask you tommy we were
just talking about the living waters of
mandalore
what do you think the living waters of
mandalore are and will they work for
someone who is not
of a true mandalorian bloodline do these
living waters know and respect people
who might have been found lanes who were
brought in to the mandalorian way of
life i i kind of wonder if
the
like entire concept of the living waters
is that they're a sentient
thing you know like they can they can
sense kind of a purity of a spirit they
can kind of you know sense malevolence
or benevolence so i'm wondering if once
mando gets there one of two things will
happen either the the waters will reveal
some kind of knowledge to him or
the waters will reject him and he'll
know what he kind of had in his heart
all along is that he doesn't belong
there um
they'll say like you have tried and we
appreciate what you've tried to do to
adopt our thinking and our way of life
but ultimately your destiny lies beyond
mandalore let let the past die well and
there seems to be a thing with
mandalorians of this strict kind of uh
what's the right word for orthodox like
belief systems so it would stand to
reason that the waters of mandala aren't
going to be as satisfying
fermando you know what i mean like
there's a chance that they're just kind
of like affirming that
the this mandalorian way is the strict
kind of specific rules and specific
uh path you have to take and mando
didn't take that path so maybe that'll
be the closure he needs to go on his own
path i have to say i love
how much mysticism we're learning about
other cultures beyond jedi um the
tuscans had their own mysticism that was
real mysticism there was a sad lizards
noses brought them to a freaking tree
vegetation on tatooine two trees yes
that we don't know where it is no one
knows where it is that had him
experiencing real visions this is true
mysticism in the same way that i think
these living waters are going to be the
same thing for dinjarin uh and i think
at the end of the day in in my you know
galaxy brain way of looking at this they
are all connected to the force it's not
the jedi dogma it's a different kind of
jedi but it is a life force that flows
through all things and then this is just
the mandalorian interpretation of it
that was just a tuscan interpretation
and last jedi luke showed us the jedi
interpretation of it but it's all the
same kind of life forces it's just
speaking to different people in
different ways so i'm so excited to see
these living waters i love that it's
living waters that we started with the
tree in the dune sea that for uh boba
fett took the form of the imagery of
crashing waves i would love if the
imagery that denjarin sees is just sand
trickling down to just give us some
parallelism there you know the living
water is giving you the driest possible
thing
i can't wait to see what this is
um
but um moving on to another question
tommy uh what the [ __ ] is denjarin's
next steps with a dark saber in
mandalore is he worthy after defeating
paz visa will beau katan ever get a
second chance well i think they're
setting it up that he
in the eyes of the mandalorians he's not
worthy right like they purposely he he
fought paz vizsla and they then
immediately banished him you know the
armor immediately banished him and he's
now kind of in company with boba fett as
two kind of former mandalorians or
people that believed in the mandalorian
way that are now kind of men with no
country but what's hard about that is
that's only true for those two cultists
for costa rice or boca bogutan for
anyone else who considers themselves a
mandalorian
being written are they gonna care that
he took his helmet off are they gonna be
like okay well you weren't truly a
mandalorian to those two but we like you
we'll follow you into war right
i think we just haven't seen enough of
that yet you know what i mean like i
think we haven't seen enough of him
interacting with more i guess woke
mandalorians that are like yeah it's all
right if you take your helmet off yeah i
don't and as for bogatan getting a
second chance like i think it's leading
up to them fighting but i think like
she's gonna think she has to kill him
well he's going to try and get her to
just take the dark saber and figure out
a way to pass it on to her like i don't
think it's a burden he wants to carry
necessarily yeah i i think the more he
becomes enlightened yeah i think he is
getting grossed out with anything
associated with jedi culture i agree
with you tommy um now i want to also ask
you what the fed will the pikes do to
those jawas and pelimoto potentially
denjarin for stealing their parts the
fact they ripped it off pike spice
runners made me a bit worried what do
you think thomas well i think uh
the the greater
uh
cost will probably be paid by pelimoto
at the jawas whereas mando's gonna you
know link up with boba fett i think
there's a chance we we may see
palomoto get either kidnapped or killed
or you know no please don't kill off any
sedation i don't mean to say that but i
think that is kind of a star wars way
though i mean like they are kind of
setting it up i mean when you when you
help the
uh side of righteousness often if you're
not a main character you're you're you
end up uh uh casualties so
i wonder if we'll lose her and the jawas
i think are always just kind of
switzerland where they're just selling
to everybody so i wonder if they just
make make it right with the uh pikes by
giving them some things they want so i
think they'll probably smooth it over
yeah i i think we have some shady trees
i think pelimoto's ex-boyfriend is in a
lot of trouble right now i think she's
gonna be like yeah look yeah he was
going through a lot of issues but
i
shouldn't have died that way
he said
he's in big trouble
um well last question tommy interesting
line about moff gideon how he was
brought to trial at the new republic
magistrate or tribunal right so what the
fed
is next from off gideon and do you think
potentially his going back to through
the new republic legal system might
bring back some of the leaders of the
new republic at this point mon mothma
uh or leia organa
uh i don't want to see her obviously on
the show uh but like an implication that
she might have passed down some order or
is this could be how we get han solo on
the show well who's going to litigate it
right like who's in charge now and who
are like who are in the upper echelon
that would be dealing because moff
gideon is like a you know a
an extremely high level threat to the
republic so he's gonna be handled by the
most powerful people so
i wonder
in my mind i think he probably is gonna
get rescued by some other evil force you
know like he's gonna get broken out
because i don't know that the trial the
trial would have to be like mon mothma
or um
holdo definitely a chance to bring her
back but i i'm not sure like yeah yeah i
just don't know because it uh
you know it would kind of be the trial
of the century it would be i mean that's
what i'm saying like i think they might
get some like celebrity uh jurists on
this panel who has to decide whether he
listens
uh former senator banks is uh getting a
jury summons like ichi and lisa have to
show up at
7 30 a.m at a courthouse hey i can't
afford
lisa have to get a stipend
we will see who ends up trying mob
gideon and whether he
probably gets away with it gets broken
out i hope so but that is it for this
episode of wikileaks again my easter egg
breakdown of the episode is going to
come tomorrow and tommy and i will be
back next wednesday with our reaction
chapter six of the pokemon potentially
see how many uh facial hairs or peach
fuzz grogu now has this this moody
teenager working for a creepy chicken
team
well uh also a quick plug to the folks
in the chicago area you can actually see
me and tommy as well as philip molina
and jessica clements in a live new
rockstar show february 11th as part of a
really cool rooster teeth live podcast
show so check the link in the video's
description for more info i'm super
excited to do this and don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
at rockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow tommy and tell me bechtel follow
new rockstars and subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcasts thank you
for watching we have
[Music]
[Music]
you